here are some things North Korea doesn't
have a human rights record to speak of
political or economic freedoms or enough
food to feed its citizens here's what
North Korea does have a nuclear weapons
program and an unpredictable young
leader whose finger is on the button our
North Korea's nuclear threats something
to fear are just saber rattling from an
isolated nation so here's the situation
at September 9th 2016 a 5.3 magnitude
earthquake was detected here it was
North Korea's fifth nuclear test in a
decade and a second this year it was
also the most powerful so far while
military experts suspect North Korea
exaggerates its achievements they agreed
his further detain of mounting a nuclear
warhead on a ballistic missile from Kim
il-sung to Kim jong-il to Kim jong-un
North Korea has been ruled by a family
of aggressive dictators since 1948 each
intent on a nuclear strategy that's deep
into the nation's isolation which is why
the u.s. currently has nearly 30,000
troops stationed in South Korea backed
with firepower such as Apache
helicopters have 16 fighters and nuclear
capable b-2 stealth bombers based in the
region now here's the argument this
could all just be a tactic North Korea
has a long history of escalating and
then de-escalating hostilities in order
to broker economic and diplomatic
concessions South Korea would support
from Japan and other nations will bear
most of the cost of providing North
Korea with fuel to make up for the
nuclear energy it is losing which leaves
the US and the world in a tricky
position most diplomatic situations call
for a carrot or stick approach
unfortunately with North Korea neither
the carrot in the form of aid nor the
stick in the form of sanctions has
worked with none of North Korea's
opponents willing to risk a military
confrontation over the nuclear issue the
most realistic options are ever stronger
sanctions were just to wait for the
downfall of the Kim dynasty neither is
ideal especially when Kim's erratic
behavior including executing his own
uncle is added to the mix